chacune de ces rivières numérique est
une chanson est sans danger au moins
c'est sûr que c'est
bonne idée
c'est beaucoup mieux tu te rends compte
que dans la première génération des
mauges il est fils n'avait pas le choix
elles étaient soit princesse soit mariée
c'est pour ça que je dois aller dans le
crabe l'abord moins je pourrai être
seule que je fais
[Musique]
oh
non c'est fini on est où là bienvenue
dans le fond d'écran
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un endroit incroyable
chaque appli est un moule voiture en
fait je peux peut être perdu
c'est quoi cet endroit wicha c'est quoi
ces peluches c'est les toutous bull
ils ont l'air tout mignon mais je te
jure ils sont hyper colorés des toutous
bulle des stickers et c'est le met à la
page mec
j'ai de mauvaises nouvelles et j'ai peur
de ta réaction
comment ça je refuse que tu ailles
travail et non attends quoi tu n'es pas
encore prêt tu me fais quoi travailler
dans le cube c'est un accomplissement
dans la vie dernier mot j tous ceux de
mon âge travaillent déjà dans téléphone
mon fils tu exagères un genou travail
libre et et les valeurs je suis une
petite robe c'est parce que je crois en
toi fiston qu'est ce qu'on doit se laver
les mains
[Rires]
kaka
ça c'est chez moi
texto police ici chacun d'entre nous
fait une chose pleurs doit toujours
pleurer même s'il vient de gagner au
loto vous mort de rire doit toujours y
même si ces conseils bras et tout ça je
suis un beauf
alors faut que je sois dans mon registre
en continu du genre off on s'en fout et
c'est pas aussi simple que ça en a l'air
sa vue les trois petits singes je les
trouve super classe posent attaché-case
pour faire ce qu'on a à faire être bien
équipé c'est toujours mieux pour faire
quel genre de truc que singeries bien
suivi koné tiroir aux émoticônes je
déteste bouscule nos ancêtres m
[Musique]